[Music]
last night was an exciting night in our
lives because it was the first time
in
well over a year we got to go see live
music going on two years oh that's right
i guess it's been yeah that long god um
something we both really missed i'm sure
a lot of you can relate uh and we got to
see of all the bands what a great way to
return
to live music uh we got to see the beach
boys
they're beach men now they're beach old
men yeah but they're still
those songs i mean
it's also two only two of them really
are in the band
the original beach boys that's not true
there's one original one original and
then what bruce johnston joined later in
the 60s but he joined right before their
seminal work pet sounds which is iconic
one of the best albums of all time oh my
god and they played a lot of the songs
last night and it was really exciting
yeah and uh it was great it was outside
so we felt safe and um guess who hooked
it up friend of the show john stamos so
thanks damos and um hey jerry you
haven't hooked us up with any cool
tickets yeah get on that that's not true
jerry invited me to a dodgers game once
what a thrill uh speaking of thrills
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your thrilled host thrilled to be
hosting justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is um
my disappointed brother i'm not
disappointed it's just a crazy guy
you're laughing because i think you're
thinking
i can't believe you're not better at
this after all this time
self-editing isn't one of your fortes
that's a nice way of saying okay so
front of the show john stamos was
married to
rebecca romain who is now married to
best friend of the show yes jerry
o'connell yeah but he hooked us up with
this really fun experience he was so
nice of him and um and we got to go
backstage that yeah we got accepted back
we john wasn't even playing because he
had injured his hand doing
who knows who knows something's sketchy
well we can call in to john and get the
scoop but um
but something happened and so he wasn't
even there and yet he still hooked it up
and uh we just said the best time those
songs you forget how many great ones
they have like one after another
it's a thrill it's surreal to get to see
uh icons singing iconic songs and the
songs that we grew up i mean that yeah i
talk about like
our formative years i mean that's when i
was first introduced to music of any
kind it was like the beach boys and the
beatles and simon garfield these iconic
songs are being played by
this iconic band and this it was a very
special first concert back out it really
was and and they're all so nice and
welcoming and uh accepting and why are
we talking about people who are
accepting yeah being accepted being
accepted backstage um well i'll tell you
why because our guest today
starred co-starred i should say and i
can actually say that in a in a little
2006 uh comedy modest
a big 2006 comedy um a movie called
accepted people know it people know it
it's actually
grown in popularity it has legs
yeah at the time it was um a modest
success i don't know what to call it it
certainly wasn't a head i i don't know
how to measure those things ever i
remember at the time thinking
well they made their money back you know
like it uh made more than the budget
right so but who cares well you started
it and uh jonah hill was in it friend of
the show blake lively hopefully future
friend of the show and our guest today
louis black
louis is a comedian that i had been
familiar with prior to
i i knew him actually prior to accepted
but not well we got to really know each
other on that movie and then
subsequently a couple years later i s i
did a play that lewis wrote we talk all
about it and um it was just so nice to
catch up with him god i
he's just one of those people you want
to spend time with he's so [ __ ] funny
he's a brilliant playwright and kind
really like warm person and a brilliant
stand-up comedian and i think most
people know him from his work on the
daily show
uh that's i think
yeah how he became very well known yeah
totally and he has a very unique persona
uh if you don't know him he's got it's
kind of an i mean you'll hear a little
bit of it in the interview but um
if you've never seen him perform he's
got this kind of like angry
he's angry an angry persona there's like
curmudgeonly
when you're
cooking um when you're boiling a big pot
of water for pasta and
the lid and it's boiling and the lid is
still on it and it's like and it's kind
of popping on and off and it's about to
boil over
that's how i would describe his persona
stage persona that's so interesting i
thought you were gonna say
when you're boiling water and and you
leave it and it starts spilling over and
burning up on the stove and you have
that initial reaction of oh [ __ ]
oh really that's what you thought i was
going to say yeah and that he is
perpetually that ah
this oh oh no i see him very differently
than you i think i i mean i see him
saying his persona i see him as con no i
know but i see that persona as simmering
like contains
boiling you're right like it's boiling
but it never boils over yes occasionally
it'll boil well let's let's okay let's
hear from them and let people decide and
then we can talk about it
um also he is i have to mention like
despite that persona the interesting
thing i've always found about him is
that underneath it is this is a real
warmth like he is um
i think similar to how don rickles may
have been is that there's a real mr
warmth yes that's right uh and lou has
that um i just love him and it was so
nice to get to catch up with them after
all this time so please enjoy my catch
up with my old accepted pal
louis black
life could be a dream
this episode of life is short is brought
to you in part by audible gather the
family for story time magic with audible
listen to imaginative heartwarming and
festive stories original podcasts and
more brought to life by incredible
performers enjoy brand new audible
originals like the cinnamon bear and
exclusives like the christmas pig by jk
rowling fire up modern classics like
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
and so many more all-time favorites
now's the time to listen together go to
audible.com
listen together
that's
audible.com slash listen together listen
now only from audible
hello
we'll meet again
[Music]
i miss human contact this is it's
disgusting
this is really disgusting
this is
more than
two people i feel like we're on
hollywood squares
i know i've found blue that um it puts a
lot more pressure on things that you're
saying you have your thrust front and
center whenever you speak so it's like
well better be good
the zoom itself is drives me nuts but
when the [ __ ] hit the fan i uh the first
10 weeks i was in complete solitary
confinement
uh and
that really uh
that's not healthy
because your brain kind of goes through
everything
uh and then goes through maybe your life
then it just comes after you
it just follows you around the house it
was horrible so and then people you know
and there's like my friend kathleen
madigan is saying um
you know there were there
folks we know you know they got families
they got you know they got they don't
have the kind of income that i was you
know and because i'm still doing the
daily show i still have outlets that i
can
you know maintain an income i didn't
know you were still doing the show
yeah the daily show that's good that's
glad to see my uh
my
my pr dollars really going to work
that's okay i didn't expect you to
follow my career afterwards after i
after i [ __ ] launched yours
in terms of finding that stuff do you do
social media you made a joke about it
lou and i just did a i do yeah yeah yeah
that really helped oh yeah yeah itself
so much you didn't know i was on the
daily show i never saw somebody who'll
show up by why gee i didn't know
it's a time my [ __ ] thing it's unless
it's on that so tick tock it's on [ __ ]
nut okay
oh i'll follow you on [ __ ] nut
yeah
um
okay i gotta fi i will i will um
i got you know you know i get a lot of
people who follow me they obviously
don't pay any attention to it but they
follow me which is fine
everybody's very excited about the
numbers you know
yeah
meanwhile my mother buries everybody you
know i put a picture of my mother who's
102 on and it's literally
you can't stop them a million plus oh
yeah she my grandmother was the same
they loved uh she just passed away
unfortunately but um
she she was 104 and so whenever she'd
have a birthday i was so she was so
proud of her age too i was always so
proud of it that i would you know that's
what social media is for so i would brag
about her having another birthday people
would go nuts yeah
is she in dc
she's in baltimore
outside of yeah just outside of paul
first of all we should
tell people that we did your play uh one
slight hitch which you had written in
the earth i started writing that 1984
wow wow but we did it a couple years ago
we did it maybe 10 10 years ago nine ten
ten years ago um a hundred years ago and
marklin baker who was one of my
favorites growing up he was a he kind of
like a physical comedy
he was like a master of timing um
mark was and his name just came up
because i had louis anderson was on the
show
and i had read ow yeah
and i had read that louie um he
he was originally cast did you know this
in perfect strangers
is that right yeah he was he was uh
cousin larry
um
originally and mark i think replaced him
after the pilot of course i didn't bring
it up to louie
um
but but i wonder was mark one of those
guys that you met through the west bank
was he one of those actors that oh i met
him at the drama school i met him
when i had finished up he was coming in
and we started and we did shows we
started working together to make money
uh we would do shows together he would
do he was a mine
which is the most disturbing thing i
could say
yeah that's sort of right it's one of
the most disturbing thing you could say
about a human being
but he was funny
uh would he perform would he like like
the play we just read would he perform
in uh parks and stuff
yeah early i mean for that yeah he would
do that when he was in high school and
stuff then in college and then we
started working
he would do a little bit of it and we
would do
improv and do some sketches and stuff uh
marcus is such crispy such precise uh
physicality that's why it's so good at
that that style and the style that your
play was written and um i i remember
saying to him once uh during a right
before a performance i said you know
because there are a lot of like
doors opening and you go in here there's
a real farce uh real like noah coward
type stuff and um
uh and and i said hey why don't we try a
thing cause we were kind of horsing
around with the door i said why don't
you try a thing where the door hits me
or you hit me with the drive i hit you
and he said uh well yeah let's rehearse
it maybe put it in tomorrow and i said
well let's just wing it and
he said um
he said bronson pinchot and i did that
once
and uh right before we we recorded
perfect strangers and he said i
i broke my nose and bronson like chipped
three or fourteen he lost a couple teeth
so that was like he's like never again
uh
always gonna rehearse from now on
um
i i didn't know this about you lou that
you got rejected from like this is like
accepted you got rejected from almost
every school you applied to
yeah
i i i i hate to oh one
all but one unc chapel hill which is a
ringing endorsement for that no no no no
actually that came later i ow
i had graduated very high
i graduated
uh third in my class at 512
from a school really pretty good
um i was the top male graduate and so um
uh i was told
you can go you're gonna be able to go
anywhere
you know that was my guidance my
guidance was
you know i said well you know i think
maybe what about i had friends going to
you i had no idea why i was going
anywhere that's not really initially
really
huh i just knew you know go to a school
you go to college what do you you know
what was i going to do you know probably
you have a good english department
that'll be good well at that point did
you have did you have aspirations to be
a performer at that point after high
school
no no i i did start to have toward the
what happened was is that um it was good
in a sense because it forced me to start
thinking about what i wanted from the
school because i applied to
to
i was told i would get into
brown amherst and williams without
breaking the sweat yale and princeton
would be a little tough uh-huh actually
the one place that i kind of was
interested in
as it rolled out was brown i didn't get
into brown which made no sense i don't
know if it was what i wrote you know
they said
in the end they finally said
uh because my s.a.t scores were
you know uh you know back then it was
like they were okay they were not great
but they were not low
but they it was i was considered to be i
was considered an overachiever that's so
weird
yeah and and and it irritated me because
i wasn't
i did all of these you know i didn't i
wasn't on a team so okay
and i wasn't elected to office but i ran
my but i was as far as i could tell the
only male in the country who ran his own
who ran the junior prom
and i ran
and i ran it on the on the basis i'm
gonna and i had a big thing i got all
500 of them in the room this is really
where i started doing my stuff i got
them all
here's what we're going to do
we're going to have a shitty junior prom
but we're going to do it right here in
the gym
and it's going to i'm going to be in
charge we're going to have some crappy
decorations it's not going to cost
anything you're going to pluck pluck
down 20 bucks maybe 30 now what's going
to happen next year you're not going to
have to pay for a really great prom at a
great place what do you say yeah
and that was it whoa that's a great idea
yeah
so that was that's the stuff i was doing
so i didn't feel like i was an idiot
yeah and it sounds like you were a
leader you were um you had like
leadership skills that you weren't
afraid to like take charge i i can't
imagine doing that in high school and i
did uh and i ran my my class trip and i
and i was allowed to have like two or
three
assemblies and i would have the
assemblies just because i knew i would
get stupid questions
so i could stand there and [ __ ] nail
them
it was great and it was so as it really
was a chance to perform
yeah
it might and it was for me it was a
chance to get laughs because i kind of
was hooked into that after i did the
first one and they're asking you know
well can we can we bring beer yeah why
don't you do that why don't you tell
everybody
why don't you stand up everybody see who
you are [ __ ]
and then and then why don't you bring
beer
and you could get away with that and the
teachers wouldn't be like oh now lewis
they loved
because
yeah exactly you're probably saying yes
yes you're living out their fantasies
and they don't have to deal with it
so they sit on the sidelines going good
slap them around i got him coming up and
with period that's right that's funny so
lu you you clearly
love performing at that age you love
getting laughs and stuff but you weren't
at that point you weren't yet thinking
oh i could do this
i really didn't know what i wanted to do
i just knew that i wanted to be involved
in theater on some level and uh
and that and so by the end of the year
after i'd gotten to kennedy screwed i
started looking around at schools
so there were schools that were
approaching me now because at that point
there were schools that were
you need you know needed students and
they were good schools
like the university of the university of
chicago but the university of chicago
didn't have a theater program and unc
chapel hills obviously a great school um
and they have such a good theater player
i mean i know a bunch of people who came
out of that it was good for me because i
got to do whatever the [ __ ] i wanted so
it was good but i arrived this is always
a tip off i arrived
within six weeks the head of the
department dropped dead
so that's always a
clue that things are really going to
work out the good omen and in that bfa
program were some really top-notch
actors
um i mean really good and that's
kind of where i focused on their work
and um
and that was where i learned started
learning it
and is that where i used to have a place
there right you must have loved i mean
you must have loved the area you must
have loved being down there yeah i
eventually i my promise was when i
graduated
that i couldn't stay there if i stayed
there i would do nothing i knew that
it's one of those places here
all you're going to do is just hang out
i've written a musical already with a
friend of mine and that had opened the
theater
at george washington university and uh
he'd written the music we'd written the
book together he wrote the lyrics no
kidding what was it about
it was called do you know where your
children are most of it took place in
the basement of a high school of the
suburbs
and it was a bunch of real [ __ ] guys
i mean it was and
uh and you know it was uh it was two
hours long without an intermission
and musicals
i'm listening two hour long musical
about a bunch of [ __ ] in a basement
yeah and the thing was
my my friend laid my it drove my friend
out of theater completely the experience
and he became a doctor
oh well he owes you a lot then
yes and but that was really kind of what
he was leaning toward anyway but this
really did it and uh
but we kept them in there two hours
because partly i said if we let them up
they're gone they're not coming back
what um so you need them to be captive a
captive audience is always the best
audience
so the next year i got a group of uh
actors from the program
some actors from the school from the unc
guys who just wanted women who wanted to
work on the show
three or four people in the film
department i wanted them to do
commercials for the show i knew what
that would be
um
then i i knew that there would be um
uh
i had some other other people some music
people
and we sat down and wrote this we uh you
know
and we would do uh you know kind of they
would do improvs and i would work off
their stuff and i would come up with
ideas
and
the idea that i had was i wanted to just
kind of tell the story of someone
growing up
and going to school you know and getting
into college just really the you know
what what high school was like take all
of our experiences distill them what was
it like
in elementary school what was it like
here what was it like here what was it
and
then it worked
it worked it was unbelievable and uh
it had a remarkable response at george
washington university no this this was
the one that was done
this was the one done after the one at
george washington
uh
uh that the two-hour no that didn't
those lives were cheap so this was done
out during north carolina this was it
done at north carolina
when i was going for the for your
fellowship
for the fellowship
and i got the department wouldn't uh
wouldn't give me uh
all i wanted i said if you give me a
thousand dollars and they were doing
you know even back then five ten eight
ten thousand dollars for production
right you know
and i would say oh i need two thousand
if it's not gonna work you i won't spend
the time i promise just let me
try to do this then what no no yeah
and so i went to the the student union
and i knew one of the guys there who's i
kind of knew him from
from campus and stuff and i said uh
here's what i want to do he said great
so we did it the response was
unbelievable we made all the money back
charging a dollar per ticket and then we
had a standing ovation every night and
then the review in the raleigh news and
observant it was this is the best thing
that's been done at the university of
north carolina undergraduate you know
it's the kind that it was just insane
the reaction was insane
it was it was all right place right time
yeah you know late 60s we kind of nailed
them
[Music]
we've been talking about how hot it is
and on a hot day you don't want to wear
like big socks i got these great low
rider socks but you do need to wear
socks because otherwise your shoes will
start to sting your feet will stink i
have the perfect solution these bomba
socks i used to hate wearing ankle socks
because they would slip into your shoes
you know my bombas never slip down and
they have treads on the bottom and they
have that moisture wicking fabric do you
know why because they're built to be
nothing but comfortable and supportive
they're the best socks hands down i've
ever put on my feet i've never worn
socks like this they have um and they
have all this technology it makes sense
that they're so good because they have
all this special hextech performance
technology wow i just know it works it
feels good
they're stitched with special moisture
wicking yarn and temperature regulating
vents that allow cool airflow in they
come in different styles for every sport
with specific design features to help
you optimize performance and keep you
comfortable no matter what you're doing
and we definitely buried the lead
because like all of their socks for
every pair of bombas performance socks
you buy they donate a pair to someone in
need in fact they donated over 45
million pairs so far so that's really
impressive i know
a cool company go to bombus.com
long today and here's what you get you
get 20 off your first order that's b o m
b a s
bombus dot com slash long for 20 off
that's almost a quarter bombus.com
long
[Music]
that's what's surprising to me louis is
that you were you wanted something to do
with theater but you weren't considering
it a viable
career path like the uh
there was no real potential for you to
do that professionally and i'm wondering
why like in high school you had oh no
not professionally i thought there was a
way to do it if i wasn't
in
anywhere but i didn't have to go worry
about going to new york wow that didn't
attract me
i didn't want i wasn't interested
this is what i wanted to do is write
theater somewhere
for folks
and i felt that eventually
it was a much longer time coming but
if we did it right
which is what happened in chicago and
places like that seattle san francisco
uh if you did it right you know they
would come calling
so uh you know that was but i was really
just i just wanted to do it i like doing
it
yeah and and that was the attraction
yeah yeah
and what what about it was the most
appealing was it the the actual writing
of it was it the process of writing
coming up with the
um
or putting it on or the whole thing it's
just sitting back and watching people
say your words
it was the whole thing it was the fact
that it was uh
that whole thing about the fact that it
was you know this it's uh you come
together it's like uh there's something
very familial about it
you form a family
there's something gratifying about that
it's a great family because uh you know
it's uh
the reason it's such a great family is
you know it's going to be oh
yes
you know that's family
yes
and you can love and hate and whatever
unconditionally because
god he's an [ __ ] but what a great
[ __ ] we are lucky to have his [ __ ]
and i thank god
and people would always afterwards
they're weeping
oh it's all over oh god
you know and i was like this is the best
part
this is glory days yeah and you're all
working uh toward a singular goal i mean
you're all working on a common goal
that's another
nice thing that separates it from most
families you know where everyone has
their own agenda
you always learn something
every time you do whatever you put a
play on you always learn you always
learn something sometimes you learn that
you you are you do know acting but you
can see objectively about actors it took
a long time for me to do that but you
can do that it's those little things
that you put it together and all of a
sudden you have this toolkit well and
you only get better that's the other
exciting thing you
it's every time you do it which is
something you love so you get to do
something you love and you get to
improve at something you love which is
really exciting it's nothing better and
then and then just to bring it on home
just since we left it was that the west
bank then became
because steve olson who runs it
rand approached him he'd been working
there with this uh
manhattan punchline a comedy theater
thing and he was rand was working for
them and he ran but wait
uh
he was running the room for these guys
and they weren't doing they weren't
successful there and man goes
i can't make i could do this better with
louis and rusty
and so he brought me in uh i did my set
of comedy for steve and
and steve knew it you know and steve
loved it
uh and that was early on and rusty was
just [ __ ] dynamite composer and uh
perform
music and so we had all the bases
covered and we
we wanted to work together and uh he let
us have the joint
well
was your stand up at that point um
was there a political slant to it were
you doing political stuff then what how
how did it start
what was the origin of it
well the
original the original stand up was all
about my sex life because that was the
funniest
i mean i talked about eventually after i
talked about myself i'd get to politics
but it was really
here's my gym teacher
explaining you know
you know in front of that you know
now he's now he's teaching a sex
education i did some really stupid we
had two dolls i'll show you sex she
takes some male 1 male dog anatomically
correct female dialect
and here's
and here's sex as we know it
and that was the joke
and it worked
you'd actually have the dog
no i did it all like the behind
[Laughter]
and i didn't do it as well there i
didn't commit i'm picturing your uh i i
i think everyone know you have such a
unique voice and
uh on stage persona and i think that's
why people are surprised to learn as i
was
to learn uh what a nice person what a
kind person you are uh how different you
are from that
from that persona were you doing
had you honed that guy yet i mean did
you have did you did it take you a while
to find that voice
no that voice is the voice in part
uh
that came from my mother in part that
was her body
um
but she had
well
and my father in the sense that my
mother had the voice but my father knew
where you know where the joke was my
mother didn't know
my mother was just like blistering
her level of sarcasm makes mine look
like
i'm like uh
i'm i'm sunscreen my mother is like full
boy you know i am the son i'm a foot
away
wow wow
she was literally
she would sit with my friends and go you
realize uh
you're gonna you're none of you're gonna
do any better than we did none of you
if you really think oh you were gonna
improve the world they're out there
marching in the streets doing your [ __ ]
what does she think of what's going on
now does she have what did she say about
i haven't been able to sit down with her
in a while so uh
you know and i'm afraid to ask if she's
her oxygen thing is not good so i'm
afraid she could really
really go this could be it
yeah
you know the joke was
she wasn't afraid of the
as much as she was she was afraid that
trump would kill her oh yeah
yeah that's for thinking about it
yeah well she made it through
yeah
um great caregivers very lucky yeah um
well i
i would i can't wait for you to catch up
it's it's funny to imagine
that character coming from
you know every time i picture i've never
met her but i picture like a sweet old
lady just because she's old but
that's such a general that's such a
prejudice that i have they're not all
sweet
one of the things i learned along the
way watching comics
you know and especially when i started
to know somewhat about what i was doing
up there because you you'd see some kid
who was kinda you knew you know your
body's not funny and then you'd sit down
and the kid was funny it's get you gotta
get this up there you know it's that
vulnerability vulnerability so they're
hiding behind some kind of personas or
some schtick uh
they're not just being honest
yeah and it's hard and that's what and i
and sometimes it's just hard to discover
it's like right in front of your face
you go where is it yeah
yeah yeah and for me it was i'm funniest
it was i'm funniest when i'm angry
and that's really it wasn't my mother
really in the end
that's when i'm funny
i just kind of get flustered and you
know and i kind of go off and and
everybody can relate to that character
yep yep and you're giving voice to a lot
of our own frustrations
uh yeah and the other thing and the and
what i got from theater
and people like
mark or geography
or you even you know and others is i'm
serious every time i see an act of work
is that
is the line you know you can go this far
with anger you can't cross that line
so i learned how to so i'm playing it
yeah so i'm acting here i'm not people
always go you're really angry well yeah
if you want to you know you're going to
show me some [ __ ] because i'll every
times i'm staging somebody will bring
something up and i just
[ __ ] literally brain
right you know emergency emergency and i
will go for about 30 seconds after you
look i've really crossed the line
that was real
it shouldn't be real
i owe you that much that's not
entertainment
that's just
me ranting and it's also
it's it's interesting you say that
because uh
it's not really entertaining as
entertaining
to watch somebody be
genuinely angry unless they're getting
their comeuppance unless it's somebody
that uh that is humiliated in some way
but to pay to watch somebody like you
a smart comedian just get genuinely
worked up i'm
yeah i'm trying to imagine what that
would be and it would be i would imagine
it'd just be dark
i mean that's what i'm wondering it's
part of the reason uh
i kind of went quiet somewhat during
but you know also i you know it's like
how come you don't
do stuff how come you're not
you know
yeah how come you're not sending stuff
out on twitter
you know shouldn't you be like hey i
don't do 144
or whatever it is words and make a joke
i'm not good i don't write jokes
yeah look at my act you know some people
caught on early it takes me sometimes a
good five paragraphs before we even
begin to meander toward a punchline
so please you know get a break but i
mean what i found was is that i never
watched a time it would have been
interesting
if we hadn't gone through this
i had already started to to say early on
from the very beginning
of his presidency that um
it was hard to
satirize what was already satiric yeah
that we were living in fiction
and that uh and
the fiction was so good
and that we knew that it was so good
because nobody who wrote fiction could
had an imagination large enough to write
this piece of fiction
because if anybody really a great writer
including even putting myself just as a
writer looking at him and going he's
running what would that mean
nobody's nobody
nobody came up to the plate
it was too much it was too hard to
imagine
yeah he was already he was already ahead
yeah already going
they're coming in you know boy they're
getting those mexicans you know boy
you know god damn it you know they're
going to eat all our avocados
[Laughter]
yeah and it's also uh i i i wonder if
when things are so bleak and divided
um
things have gotten to a point now where
to address them comedically is
i guess difficult but i i also wonder
how funny it is you know um
i mean i had gotten to the point that
one of the things i'd gotten to before
the [ __ ] really hit the fan was a
section of my act where i said that we
had done something no other country had
done which is that we were
we actually
most two-party systems
exist uh along uh the fault line is is
that between them is between their ideas
and what had happened here was we were
the first country ever
uh in which um people actually were
fighting over realities
and and the thing that i do know about
whatever reality you choose i said what
i learned from acid is eventually you
come down
that's true
what do your memories have accepted we i
just remember having fun but i have such
a bad memory that uh
i i'm hoping you'll you'll remind me of
a fun anecdote or something um
i i just remember how much fun it was
yeah it was just fun we did the scene by
the trailer i remember that
that was a great scene but that was
mostly scripted i think my memory is a
viewer that they
and i saw the movie recently i was i was
with some friends they hadn't seen it
and
um
it's a little embarrassing but i set
that aside and watched and really
enjoyed it which is also embarrassing to
say
oh it's good it's a funny [ __ ] movie
it was directed nicely it was a really
good cast and
it didn't dwell on your relationship so
it didn't become where you
you know it was like okay we got it my
mother said
about it one of the things she liked the
movie she said there was no reason he we
got it you know they're there's you know
they they now they like each other yeah
yeah
the one thing i do really remember was
when
when they i saw it and then um and the
reviews came out and they torched us and
i was like are you what are you kidding
me yeah yeah
are you [ __ ] kidding me this is
this is a really funny [ __ ] movie and
it's silly and
and then it did huge afterwards i mean
it literally exploded i mean i am known
in a lot of ways by
a younger audience more for that than
stand up no kidding i was going to say i
wondered if people
yeah people have found it then over the
years
yeah you're that guy that's one of my
that's my favorite movie oh that's funny
i just watched it last night oh that's
that's serious it's like great that's
funny that's great every other [ __ ]
movie ever done like that got a sequel
everyone
well um blake lively is now making 8
million dollars a year after that after
that movie and jonah hill oh yeah he's
making three million why can't we do it
well justin just got a three picture
what the [ __ ] and uh and the other two
they don't even know they're doing
commercials
so it would cost 400 million dollars to
get it you're the only one that's still
cheap
[Music]
well that's not true i would do it i'd
do it in a heartbeat but i i um
i i was noticing that a lot of your
lines in that um
i think most of which you improvised if
i'm not mistaken
yeah they just let you go and um
and and there's something so kind of
like uh
relevant now about those lines when you
talk about society and not conforming to
uh you know at the standard you go to
college you get a job make money there's
something very
anti-establishment about
the message that you deliver in that
movie um
if that really holds up it's really kind
of like
there's something kind of punk rock
about it uh yeah
i loved it life could be a dream
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island
reality tv was beginning to dominate the
airwaves and every show needed to be
bigger flashier more scandalous than the
last but in the case of one infamous
dating show the real drama was happening
off-screen and it would shape the future
of reality tv the reality tv series
there's something about miriam seemed
like a pretty standard dating
competition six young men vibed for the
affection of miriam rivera a beautiful
model from mexico but when miriam
revealed that she was a trans woman
during the show's finale the on-screen
drama sparked an international uproar
about gender sexuality and whether
reality television had finally gone too
far follow harsh reality the story of
miriam rivera on apple podcast amazon
music or you can listen early and add
free by joining wondering plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge watching low
budget made for tv holiday movies the
all new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wandery plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
[Music]
we have a lightning round what is your
most commonly used emoji you don't use
emojis do you
most commonly use emoji
i have a friend who likes a unicorn
and so then
but that's not my the either middle
finger
no you don't you don't use them i use a
smiley face sometimes because it's just
easier oh you do okay
but just
smile not that [ __ ] goofy head
[ __ ] okay okay yeah i i admire your
restraint i thought you were gonna make
fun of me more for the line maybe so
often flame
flame i might use
really a glass
okay if you could be
a professional athlete what sport would
you play
what's the one where you ski and do
shooting um
that would be it
okay that would never happen uh if i
could be a professional athlete i'd be
uh god
i'd be a golfer
oh yeah but really but a real pro but
you know but uh i would
uh yeah that would be it
do you watch sports are you a sport
sports guy no
yeah i do uh it takes away the pain
okay but um it's new york tv
no
i i don't like the yankees so much i'll
watch them to hope they lose my
teammates uh
is baltimore and uh okay
and they are horrific on levels that's
unimaginable but what a great park
camden yards oh my god that
terrific
yeah
oh i had a day there by myself i got
a ticket once there just sat there by
myself it was the best um
you're at the ga you're at the game or
you're watching tv uh if you get up one
snack food what is your go-to snack food
lewis black as the blades triscuits and
hummus
there's a blade guacamole
oh yeah what is your favorite movie
sequel of all time the sequel to what
one that we weren't in
okay
okay that one was just great i heard
that's good i refuse to watch it because
i'm not in it
um
what's your go-to character you might
make fun of me for this what's your
go-to karaoke song
um it's uh
just a city girl dude
oh i took the midnight train
yeah
what just a small town girl uh what is
that
okay
and i do it uh i do this thing for the
cystic fibrosis foundation every year we
have a big
golf thing that we do we weren't able to
do it they called the ultimate golf
experience i've been doing it for 25
years and i kind of host it
and um
and then the last five years i've been
uh that's the that's the go-to song oh
really
uh they're not doing it this year
we're gonna we're gonna try to do it it
won't be on the level but we've been
able to do it because of all this you
know right
um what's it called
what's that called louis i
god i can't believe this
it's journey of the journey don't stop
believing of course
it's that one but it's also the other
one um i want to ask you this why you're
not thinking about something else so it
just comes out
uh who was your first celebrity crush
mighty mouse's girlfriend oh
not minnie mouse no mighty mouse's
girlfriend who was that
serious not phony cello actually oh yeah
okay
that was another joke that i used to do
initially i fell in love with my
mouse's girlfriend and then that
michelle showed up at mousey
and it wasn't sure if it was the mouse
ears
[Music]
yeah you see why i'm not doing a
nostalgia show
so the mouse ears were like a gateway
attraction yeah um
um if you have to get a tattoo and i
know you're you're covered with tattoos
if you had to get one what would it be
have you ever thought about that
no
my brother had a great idea which was um
his idea was which i was thought was the
best was have the lacoste alligator
right above the nipple
and then you have a shirt or wherever it
is on the thing and
it's over here i guess and then
you would
rip out a hole there and
so you'd always
be wearing a lacrosse shirt
that's really funny that's really funny
um
that's good i i think that'd be good
good for people to who have a lot of
tattoos that'd be a good um because i
think if you get a cert enough tattoos
at a certain point you just start doing
them for
shits and giggles
you just get started getting joke ones
i can't i've never thought of having a
tattoo
all right uh what you're what's your
favorite fruit lou
probably berries uh blackberries um
strawberries but they gotta be
strawberries really need to be not those
shit-ass ones you know good
yeah
not the ones that taste like paper
um
you know blackberries uh the um
those are the those are the those those
are the ones i i'm not a major fruit guy
um who is uh
yeah there's nothing like a ripe
strawberry we have a lot of wild ones
but they're so tiny some of them are
like this they're just this little
little burst of flavor um who would you
want to play you in the lewis black
biopic in the in the lewis black story
oh you
ah i'd love it
yeah you
yeah yeah but
i could get you cheap
and it would never get made
uh who's your favorite simpsons
character
luisa
yeah
okay i know because she's played by
uh and i think it's because of just
prejudice she's played by the the first
girl who did um
uh
pb
in arena stage 100 years ago she did oh
yardley smith that's right
oh my god pb is a character in lou's uh
play oh that's right
uh dogs are cats do you prefer
dogs um beetles are the rolling stones
you probably i
lean toward the stones uh have you seen
them live
yeah
my first concert that i went to was the
rolling stones oh no kidding wow i was
15
and their first concert tour oh my god
that's uh 1968
63 no 60 64 i think
wow
what was that like where was that
it was in a place called uline arena in
washington d.c and and was that when
they were just breaking was that people
must have yeah
wow
nine by five or something like that you
know uh by the way
oh wow
get off my cloudy
yeah they only did like uh 25 30 minutes
oh wow they had like three opening acts
the vibrations opened they oh
they were unbelievable that was just as
overwhelming as the stones in a way
oh wow you used to see a lot of music
back then when you were a teenager
no that was just i i went down my
friends and i just went down i didn't
really start to
i had other friends who were really
smart and went down to
howard and saw everybody james brown
everybody
but i didn't know they were going down
there and um
but i uh it wasn't really until
probably by the time
my senior year in high school i started
going i went and saw the temptations i
saw four tops
how cool oh god um
yeah seinfeld is on and friends is on
is it an easy choice who what do you
watch take a nap
okay
uh ketchup or mustard or both
mustard
ah okay um
and and
what are two adjectives that you would
want people to use to describe you after
you're gone you get to witness your own
funeral um what are two words that you
feel like you would hope that people
would use to describe you
funny [ __ ]
uh
i and and i love you so much that like
and know you well enough to never be
able to encapsulate you into words i
mean i wouldn't know how to reduce you
and and i'm not you but um
yeah
well i hope we get to see each other at
some point okay well thanks buddy i
can't wait to see you can we see you
take care okay
[Music]
so so that that [ __ ] happened that
happened
yeah dope so
no one swears better than him no [ __ ]
the [ __ ] does that mean i mean
sometimes i love when he gets so
worked up that he like he does this
thing where he like he shakes his his
lips in a way that they make that like
no like it's like cartoons he's like
yeah he's like angry roger rabbit
yeah he's like
eddie
it is funny to hear
i've never heard him on a podcast that
was the uh air conditioner
it is hot you're starting to get a
little mustache sweat thank you for to
paint a picture for the listeners
your brow is getting pistoled one thing
i'm looking forward to about the summer
ending is um
there's no more mustache sweat
it's a real
problem for me yeah it's beating up
right now i know well i'm doing it for
you now i'm not going to wipe it off
because i'm going to make you look at it
gross you're oh i thought you were
encouraging your pores to sweat produce
no what do you think louis would say if
we kept this all in and he was listening
to him oh jesus christ who wants to oh
come on you trash
oh bro good good because i needed to
take a [ __ ] nap
he is so
good at like um
it's it's a certain type of
humor that was i think really popular in
the 50s and 60s i i heard a story about
don rickles and how much robert de niro
like idolized don rickles kevin pollock
tells this great story and
he said it's because in the 50s when de
niro was growing up uh there were two
different types of gangs
there was like the gang like that would
fight with their fists like you know and
stuff and um like the violent gang and
then there was like the insult gang
that's how they like
dealt with one another it was like your
mama jokes
yeah i know a gang you'd be in yeah the
way you described the first gay guy
you know they'd fight with their fists
and stuff
cuffs
you know slapping each other and whatnot
and or your mama jokes yeah either one
by the way i just don't know i want to
say yo mama jokes probably because it is
your mama it's not your mama i know but
isn't that like you know your mother
joke i know but isn't that uh
appropriating a culture a little bit
saying yo mama i guess it is your mother
your mother jokes you're very sensitive
well it's that it's the time we live in
yes it you have to be i guess it's
it's easier for me to be less sensitive
yeah you can say yo mama yo mama but if
you
there was a sh i guess i can say too
there was a show called yo exactly that
art for former friend of the show not
current front of the show once you're a
friend of the show you're a friend of
the show wilmer wilmer valderrama front
of the show yeah um what was the way he
um two gangs two gangs yeah so de niro's
so
de niros was in the insult gang and of
course there was no better there was no
like he
don rickles was the insult king and i i
wonder if cause lou grew up during that
time
and i wonder if that's how he honed uh
maybe subconsciously you should get him
on the show and ask him oh man oh man
yeah yeah he is a bit like don rickles i
didn't i didn't realize that but now
that you say that that's true yeah he
had because there's like
he's
he can cut you down but there's a lot of
warmth underneath it like a lot of like
kindness yeah and his love he's like you
could tell he loves you yeah yeah his
tell him and
don rickles had a tell which was like
after he'd say a thing like that it'd be
like a twinkle in the eye it was all
almost imperceptible but it was like if
you were to act it you'd have to really
feel it you know it wasn't a thing like
he wouldn't burst out laughing he
wouldn't like like sometimes if jimmy
fallow
yeah there was no
it wasn't overt but it was clear
does that make sense it was like lou's
thing is like he gets a
this won't obviously translate because
this was not um a visual thing but he'll
get like a the slightest like this sweet
like mischievous smile a little bit like
the beginnings of a smile
it's i love it it's really like but it's
clear it's like and if it's not clear
then whatever he's insulted you and you
don't like him
um but what's it's interesting we were
talking about earlier but the difference
between
uh like what is a persona
and is a persona
like what's the difference what's the
real difference between a persona and a
personality so if do they blend i mean
at that point if you've adopted a
persona for long enough see i always
thought personas were completely put on
like it was a character you were playing
i did too uh in a show or something like
that's a persona i think there's a i
think it's relative i think there's a
gray area i don't think it's
like gilbert godfrey for example i
remember meeting him and being really
struck by how restrained he was just
because i had only known him as that guy
who talks like you know he was always
pushing and as it turns out i should
have known this at the time but he's so
committed to that
that guy i never saw him do anything
else that when i met him and he was just
like hi i'm gilbert you know like
kind of a muted
version i realized that that was
an act but
there was still an element of that in
his
in his personality that persona now like
and every once in a while he'd be like
what you know he would kind of go into
it right and lou does the same thing
yeah it's almost like it's um his
persona isn't a persona per se it's more
a part of his personality that only
comes out sometimes it's like amplified
right well he said he's like i'm i
realized at a certain point i'm
funniest when i'm angry yeah um
so the anger isn't completely put on
like it comes from he accesses it in
inside of him somewhere
but it's still
he has an awareness that
it's entertaining it's entertaining yeah
it's a little bit like i think he has
some of the dna of like a borscht belt
comedian he's gonna love that i'm saying
this but like that style that like cat
skills new york jewish
comedic sensibility which was so big and
like that sid caesar and mel brooks
those guys all popularized um
carl reiner like he he
there was you could insult someone and
take my wife please is like the classic
joke from that which is like
you know there's that great joke
floating around that that you've been
playing yeah i love that i was just
thinking about when you do that well
it's it doesn't well you have to see it
it's just it's just a video
of a of a man
like a middle-aged older man and you
hear a voice ask him
okay so you have two choices
a
spend the rest of your life with your
wife
or b
yeah so you just b
it's one of my fa i think there's
something so brilliant it's the
construction i don't know what he looks
to there's something kind of like i know
it's such a great performance yeah it's
like so desperate to like get out of
this situation
yes
yeah but it's it's um there's something
about it that's what those jokes had and
seinfeld comes out of that like there's
an efficiency there's like a simple yeah
but the construction of it is really
brilliant um
the the the lang the way they they use
language is like very clear you forgot
that he was on the daily show you didn't
know that he was on the daily show still
i didn't know he was still i didn't
either oh yeah i i guess because i
haven't seen the daily show in a while
but also like i i don't know i you know
every once in a while i'll see like like
a clip of it on it'll pop up on
instagram or something
and i just haven't seen him on it he's
going to love hearing this too oh great
you want to bring that up again i
haven't seen the daily show hearing his
voice like commenting on one up because
he's so often comments on things i say
do you think he'll hear this um i think
so
lou
how about this louis if you're listening
to this send me back
just send me an emoji of
um
botswana botswana
the flag of botswana botswana
what kind of show is that so i guess
anyone could have a show it was funny
you were nervous to ask him what his
favorite emoji is and you were like oh
yeah
what's your favorite emoji you don't use
emojis i said that right after you asked
them you're like what's your favorite
emoji you don't use emojis
and much to your shock and my shock he
does yeah what did he say he was like a
unicorn and oh he's like
a glass of red wine
and a fire emoji he was like a flame
oh really i remember that
and then he was like he said he was like
usually like a smiley face but not one
of those like goofy i forget how he said
it but like goofy like goofy heads
emojis it's like an old-fashioned one
that's funny just like with the regular
like not even a smile
sometimes i use those ones that are like
barely smiling
like this
yeah i've been using them with mom
lately when she she'll like demand that
we'd run an errand or something and uh
and your boss
my boss mom
well you're part of the family business
yeah i would say uh oh well you know i
don't want to embarrass her because she
might listen to this but she probably
won't our mother likes to listen to the
ones that are like
that she has some
that are like really what would you say
like she has some kind of no she might
listen to this she might
don't you feel like we're part of a
family business but we don't get paid
yes yes
yeah like low-level mafia family
this like not a criminal mafia family
and we're like we're like the suns and
goonies yeah but but
if they had been nicer we're like the
kapos in like a
uninteresting like non-criminal of mafia
family
uh you asked what sport he'd want to
play and he said the one where you uh
ski and do the shooting
um and when he said that it was so funny
to picture him doing that skiing down a
hill
pulling kind of i believe it's called
biathlon that how it is it's such a
goofy sport i can't believe that's a
sport i can't believe people have you
seen it it's really strange people ski
and shoot at the same time no you ski
and you ski and then you stop and then
you pull out oh
it might it must have some roots and
it's really like impressive that you
can't do either of those things well
combine them it's such a strange thing
to combine what would be stranger than
that i guess maybe uh archery wouldn't
arch would be
maybe harder because you'd have to hold
two different things
how do you hold the poles so you ski
down without poles
um
no i think you ski down and then you
have like a little thing in your back
like a little backpack in here and you
pull
who's good what countries are good at
that probably like
scandinavian yeah i was gonna say i was
gonna guess at uh maybe norway hmm
yeah i've never yeah and like are those
sports big like do people watch those
sports in those countries i wonder how
big they are i'm i mean obviously
they're bigger like what's the biggest
curve then they are here but i wonder if
they even
are big where
they're big what i have has there been
an olympic sport that got like phased
out
i i'm sure
it's a good question i'm wondering i
think so
there's some
like i there's been a lot of ones that
have been phased in lately like
skateboarding golf yeah yeah when you
asked him who his first crush was or is
uh for celebrities oh wait yeah and
without missing a beat what did he say
he said um he said mighty mouse's
girlfriend oh
without missing a beat like
like people ask him that every day
that's crazy that's right i remember
that like he didn't have to it's amazing
well
it was just right here
yeah he accessed it right away kids are
often attracted to
cartoons i was yeah you know both of you
attracted cartoon characters i was very
attracted to the maid marion you both
have to be attracted to maine marion
that is that you're going to say yes
may marion
i mean
hood talk about sexy so so was robin
hood okay
he was though you know what was sexy
about the robin hood was that um again
same with uh tom brady they had this
he had a real command he had a real like
presence and like i'm going to do this
you're just going to take care of it
yeah yeah you could you could trust him
well that's why any super like that's
why christopher reeve was sexy right
superman and that's why right any hero
any heroic figure is sexy i think that's
right clark kent wasn't as sexy because
he was like
he was like bumbling oh not nearly a
second wishy-washy even though he looked
the same
that shows how important that confidence
and that personality is that's how that
character worked right is that that you
could believe him because and that's why
christopher reeves was good so handsome
yeah but because he was like hey lois
he was not sexy you know it it it's a
little harder to buy henry kevland i
don't mean this like from his acting or
anything only because he is so
[ __ ] ripped in those movies and so to
buy a guy who is and christopher reeve
was obviously in good shape but they
covered it up and he was a he wasn't so
like muscular right it was like bulging
like lats and like [ __ ] he just
that it's hard to buy a guy who i agree
but can i also just say what christopher
reeve was a much better actor
i can say that i don't want to say that
fine i can say that he was yeah much
better yeah um when you asked him what
you're talking about please keep that in
uh when we were talking about um what
your favorite fruit is he was like i
guess berries
are funny
and it's funny to hear something so like
whimsical and like and like like like in
a sense yeah that you like pop into your
mouth said that way but then after he's
so funny after he had this like little
back and forth about fruit he goes i'm
not a major fruit guy yeah
and i was like oh that's such a great
name for his autobiography i'm not a
major fruit guy the lewis black story
yeah that is funny
yeah hey batteries and did i talk about
how they have like the really high
antioxidants like i know they are for
you oh good i probably wanted to because
i've been like thinking about that a lot
uh but the two words he would pick about
himself are funny [ __ ] and that would
be i mean talk about the perfect name
for his book i know funny [ __ ] i know
it's sam rockwell uh friend of the show
has a great shirt his favorite shirt is
a shirt that says it was given to him by
chuck berris
from the gong show and when he played
him in the movie and uh it just says a
little [ __ ] on the back that's cool
it's such a great shirt for sam um
speaking of fruits uh not uh i know we
don't like to like
really discuss
past episodes of the show
but i don't i know but in the seth grain
episode i noticed something that you
overlooked i can't believe you missed it
the way i asked him about uh fruit was
like the way i used to do it i know i no
believe me i noticed it it was gross it
crossed me out i didn't want to reopen
an old nose okay all right like i'm
doing
yeah but i did it in such a like i did
notice that you were like a nice piece
of right you just like bite right into a
juicy by the way speaking of have i i
think i've talked about it on an
upcoming episode but the nectarines that
i've been having lately i had one of
those 15 minutes ago aren't they 15
minutes before we started aren't those
incredible delicious oh my god look at
that explosion of flavor yes shout out
to aaron uh at the the otis farm farmers
market who supplied us with these
incredible nectarines and he recommend
he said because we were going to get the
peaches and he said
my friend said should
should we get something else and he said
you know i think the nectarines are
better and he was right and i
like i love when uh
people are honest like that
great story do you want to read a letter
sure okay this is from stacy garcia
lewis
stacy garcia-lewis stacy spelled
s-t-a-c-i lewis yeah great
subject um
kind of a down
uh face kind of like a saddish face
looking down uh headphones
the number
uh hashtag sign and a smiley face
that's the subject oh how would you say
that first emoji
that's one of my favorite emojis i
should know how to say uh mournful
mournful yeah kind of sad
hey justin and christian i'm sh that's
not one of my favorite emojis you do the
one where it's like sweet yeah like
bashful yes
yeah it's the one right before that one
and then it gets more mournful hey
justin and christian i am sure most
emails you get go on about how great
show is and how much you are appreciated
but that is because you all make such a
difference for so many people oh i
thought i thought it was going to be i
thought she was supposed
thanks stacy um this is another one of
those emails she says it's funny i can
only speak for myself but in this past
year having your podcast has gotten me
through some of the most difficult times
in my life wow caring for an immune
deficient toddler and a newborn baby
while working a job that required me to
be close to people during a pandemic was
not for the faint of heart i bet
good lord
listening to your all's banter anecdotes
and funny stories was such a bright spot
in my week as a newly single mom days
are long and times are trying but i
always know that i have tuesdays to
listen to a new episode that never fails
to make me smile and laugh
ah man stacy thank you i'm going to cry
um
speaking of crying did you see that ed
asner passed away very sad uh yeah that
now he's just talking about up he had a
great run though he was old he's nice i
know what a great actor
anyway sorry um
back to stacey your podcast has been
like a friend to me and means more than
you'll ever know to so many people thank
you for what you do and for just being
you that is so nice
so nice i think about that sometimes
when we're doing this where it's like i
think about people i know people that i
love just like hearing us and kind of
like
hanging out with us a little bit
you know do you ever think that about
that when you're doing it when you're
talking yeah especially
certain people who i know listen yeah me
too
um
you know both have to think about
certain people that you know listen
while you're doing the show uh and now
for some would you rather's would you
rather listen to great would you rather
listen to a dog wine or a baby cry for
an entire day
just for 24 hours though not forever
that would be too cruel uh that's a good
question easy frog wine or a baby cry
hey yeah me too
baby cry because it's like it's
connected to suffering
as is the dog whining
i think i've just also
i value the life of a baby and like the
pain of a baby more than the pain of a
dog but so do i i just said that i just
said it's connected i mean i don't
both are bad obviously but uh
hearing a baby
cry is like really painful for me it is
whereas i've also had a lot more
experience
um hearing
you
we've heard like there's a dog that
we've gotten kind of desensitized lives
near us that is like
kind of constantly yeah whining you mean
across the pond yeah yeah that i hear a
lot of so i've gotten a little
desensitized to that well that and pearl
our parents one of our parents dog
there's max and pearl and pearl is um a
real whiner whenever she's away from my
father if that because they'll put a
little like baby gate up uh when their
grandkids come over and pearl's just
like constantly it's constant yeah i've
become a little numb to it
is that your stomach yes wow is
cavernous sound that is hungry you must
be starving i need a perfect bar um
sponsor but also i love them that's uh
yeah i just sort of got used to it but
if you hear a baby whining it's like i i
mean i don't have babies so whenever i
do hear them it's not that often when i
yeah i like it's funny to see you panic
i know it's like oh god it's like a fire
though
i know
a friend was telling was telling me
about their um because i've been
thinking
you know i'm like curious about people
raising babies and um
uh they were telling me about how they
were sleep training their their kid uh
the idea is that you have to just like
let them cry i've heard that they put
them down that would be so hard it would
be so hard for me but he said i mean
it's totally paid off now because like
after a couple days of he he said it was
like torturous but like you just have to
stick to it
um that would be really hard for me um
anyway
great question
uh would you rather and oh there's
another one awesome would you rather
look in a mirror and watch while having
a major surgery performed on you without
being able to hear
or
to not be able to see the surgery but be
able to hear everything huh
um that's a good question
i've
should we settle on what the surgery is
yeah you'd have to let's say hernia
surgery oh that's my so i've had me too
you know both have hernia surgery um
so let's say it's hernia surgery i would
rather
um as long as here's my answer if i had
confidence in my doctor and the team i'd
rather be here i would rather i'd rather
not see and just hear it me too because
it's like i
i trust that they know they're doing
i don't need to look at the incision or
anything
but if i was more nervous about who was
doing the surgery i think i'd want to
see just to make sure i kept tabs on it
absolutely me too
that's a good question did i tell you
about um when i had my hernia surgery i
asked the doctor to film me while i was
going out i remember that yeah for jimmy
fallon cause i was gonna and i wanted
him to ask me about jimmy fallon because
i was gonna go on jimmy's show a couple
days later and they were gonna play it
and um
i when i saw it back i was like hey
jimmy i
i should be doing your show i could do
what you do and i was like weirdly like
like combative
not combative but i was like
i was strange that that was my like
inside because i don't think i could do
that but maybe somewhere inside me i do
maybe you do
man so i couldn't play it on jimmy's
show that's funny i told him about it
though he was like ah it's funny
um anyway uh what a great letter thank
you question though that's interesting
to think about i know it is
and and i guess it's about what you um
what what triggers you more what's more
uh what you're more squeamish about this
the sense that that that you're more
squeamish about
i guess if
i guess i just visually would just be so
freaked like the sounds of those things
would be kind of unsettling for sure
like
like cutting into the body like
certainly cutting into any bone or
anything would be like i remember when i
had that my teeth filed down it was like
oh that was horrible the teeth is
different yeah but but to see it it
would be really jarring that'd be
upsetting i can't it's hard that's why
among many reasons why i couldn't be a
doctor to see blood and all that yes and
you need to go to school for a certain
amount of years that's also true and get
good grades yeah and be accepted oh yeah
yeah full circle all right so uh and and
back to stacey's letter yours truly it's
just yours truly stacy garcia lewis
thanks stacey that's really nice
and if you want to write a letter great
or otherwise
uh you can do so by writing to life is
short at wondery.com
and um
man i want to thank i hope he's
listening but remember lou botswana the
flag of botswana if you're listening uh
botswana what is this a [ __ ] test
um i want to thank him so much he is
just one of my favorites i'm so so lucky
to have worked with him uh to have and
to have gotten a chance to catch up and
thank you for listening to our ketchup
yeah great great talk smart funny yeah
solid solid app
yeah yeah it was a good app that was a
good episode oh yeah i don't want to
hear any of the bad ones
um
we love him and uh thank him and
uh go watch accepted oh yeah it's on um
one of those streamers it's on something
i think i think it's definitely making a
comeback i think it's on netflix i keep
hearing people talk about accepted more
lately yeah i think it really has legs
that way it's been it's been accepted by
the netflix community and i get a little
uh some residuals every time so uh yes
the [ __ ] sandwich that's right um that's
so cool uh so thank you and if you wanna
yeah if you wanna support uh either of
us uh with residuals go ahead and watch
it we'll talk to you next week okay
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me was hosted
by me and still will be next week justin
long i hope and it's co-hosting
co-produced by you christian long it's
also produced by megan v monaco a senior
producer is michelle miesh
and the audio engineer is sergio
enriquez the executive producer is
father marshall louis and the
company that we all work for is
wondering
[Music]
ah i love provincetown provincetown my
favorite places
it's great it is fun just to like
drink all those bars and like meet
people everyone's so friendly christian
spent a whole night cognabbing yeah
christian spent a whole night i'm not
being with this
guy oh the guys are so nice that's why i
spent all night with this guy bobby
weatherby bobby weatherby
[Laughter]
it's so it's so evocative that name it's
so like perfect
i just got tired i was done singing and
i was like
he was like
he was like floored well in his defense
and his defense christian
spent the whole night in provincetown
yeah they were and they ended up singing
like show tunes broadway show tunes at a
piano bar at like three in the morning
say that because she was like
if yeah imagine bobby weatherby's
surprisingly you're like
well anyway
put her there together
he was like good night and then he like
got kind of mad i could see like the
waves of motion sitting
and then he was like denial and he was
like wow are you really going all right
and then he likes is this some game
really funny you had no idea that he was
no not at first at first i was just like
tonight and then when he got incredulous
i was like oh he
thinks that i wanted
did you were you ever like do you ever
was there a moment where you consider
just like giving him like like a good
night kiss but i used to use this little
like bald like
firecracker bobby weatherby
i don't know why i picture with him like
with it with a
uh a toupee and like no he's like a
little like like around here
like makeup like a little bit of rouge
arrested development no like rip taylor
eye picture i'm picturing rip taylor no
he was a little bit like mickey rooney
and balder oh
fun what does that look like like a
stamp she's a champion yeah puck puck
hobby weather oh that's your type
[Laughter]
you